let's talk about condoms everybody loves condoms right?
very the some new condom technology
that's right the Galactic cap which
claims to be stronger and safer than
traditional condoms
and enable better sensitivity we've got
an image
up the cap okay so what's happening here
should we put a a parental warning on
this video or graphic let you know that
then that would mean very horrific a
sorry guys sorry lady I alright so this
babe Bailey like a tiny little
cap that goes on the top the penis the
replicator
expose you to get more sensitivity
everyone in the city is really get the
cat is laying
I remember one other parts were its most
sensitive though at the Guyana
tip with him now the cabinet at the S
and L A Lee subject generally lower than
the tip but the tape
you know me below the tip okay talk that
they brought the
no I just the tip yeah okay so because I
don't make compromises to park the U
shaped polyurethane
adhesive film that wraps around the
penis that you saw their
it sorta like a plastic ran a finger and
a cap that sticks to firmly
crap the theme in so a guy basically
a could wear this all time and be ready
for sex at any time a do you think men
would
ever women have to be on birth control
Iranian women didn't have taken
responsibility
for their reproductive health their
sexual many doesn't seem to me that
would be able
going away rate for a long time and I
think it bill know it now
a 00 saying it might happen
yeah I think there's nothing that's
going to happen before you get eight
then they're gonna gonorrhea and her bf
because there's only protects against
pregnant the other than protecting and
any STD's so
right well I guess there's some question
whether it'll protect against sum up the
STD's because it does practice
seen it it a strategy into the skin on
skin stuff so I could still do it some
questions related to that
but just to be a little clearer about
how this thing actually works for you
could literally
be wearing it all the time and then
would you want to have sex if you can
buy them at willing to do with you
I am not peel off the paper backing on
the cap
and stick it to the polyurethane to
secure the bond between
a
the yeah too but due to between the two
yeah you know cuz the penis is an organ
well known for always having the right
amount of friction and always being
dried
I'm sorry yeah I'm
I love them that you can wear it all the
time anytime
I think it's crazy to think that a woman
will be like
oh you know for the first time you know
getting you know have the Pennine or
whatever and then alternately the pedi
you don't hear that led to our baby
backing of it lookout Hill mean the Pens
are down in a new CNN you like bill call
up and also I'm thinking the Cupra
meditated this to change that with so
many others before me like
lol %uh not happening you're not getting
laid to beware that right and Ohio
so okay so for you guys if you were on a
date with a guy and then
you know you got back to back to his
place your place where your
and then I got naked and he already had
one of those on
not happening you be like what well yeah
all you need to know you didn't know
when it waived
yeah but League yeah I like a you really
hung up on the
I know what the hell am I guys don't
like to
you know darnell until about cleanliness
yeah no roads and dirty no you didn't
know that he detested appear gonna be
wearing that the plan
yeah I think when alright well I guess
I'm gonna pass you my final question or
two
which was do you think this kind will
finally revolutionise eight sex it
sounds like that happen to be me
maybe in like a really committed
long-term relationships or whatever
we're like they the pill is giving you
like the girl
on the allergic reaction or morning
sickness like girls are fucking awful
so this is an alternative to using the
pill and the like committed monogamous
relationships are
yet but going back to what I said
earlier did is for guys it just seems
like guys just aren't responsible
another would you even would you even
trust the guy if there was something
that was really like that small
I mean would you trust him to you know
to me like you turn your head for
several you know he ripped that they
gnaw
and you may not even know everybody
wanna do I wanna get me pregnant
more keep he just may want more cities a
shelf that he's being so
well I think yeah with Parker i like it
so much baby man
that came to obey the men with that lot
of a pin man